[Musik]
[Applaus]
am ende dieses wahlkampfes gab es so ein
paar reizthemen die dann vor allem nehme
ich mal an die junge generation
mobilisiert hat also da hat sicher das
video von visionen eine rolle gespielt
aber auch artikel 13 8 lot filter und so
weiter
am wochenende sind die eu-wahlen und es
ist wichtig wählen zu gehen aber es ist
genauso wichtig eine rationale
entscheidung bei der wahl so viele sich
fürchteten ja wenn das so kommt dass die
nationalisten die rechtspopulisten oder
vielleicht auch die linkspopulisten so
stark weil werden wie das vorhergesagt
wurde
dann nehmen die dieses europa
auseinander dann kapern sie die
europäischen institution und dann sind
wir dabei die europäische union
abzuwickeln so stark ist es nicht
gekommen
und dann muss man glaube ich auch
fairerweise sagen es hat in etlichen
ländern auch kommunalwahlen
stattgefunden und das zusammen hat
vielleicht dazu beigetragen dass die
wahlbeteiligung höher ist aber ich
glaube schon grundsätzlich muss man
sagen es ging bei der wahl schon auch
darum wertschätzung für europa der eu zu
zeigen und das hat viele zum wahllokal
getrieben gleichwohl wird das
europäische parlament noch fragmentierte
als bisher manche sogar pulverisiert das
heißt es gibt nicht mehr das alte pohl
aus christlichdemokraten und
sozialdemokraten und auch die grünen
spielen alle jetzt eine maßgebliche
rolle
die liberalen spielen eine maßgebliche
rolle es wird eine starke
rechtspopulistische portion geben es
wird noch eine konservative fraktion
geben die kräfte werden mehr und das
coli und die koalitionsbildung wird
schwieriger werden es ist nicht mehr nur
automatisch eine sache eine einigung von
christdemokraten und sozialdemokraten
bisschen komplizierter werden das ist
aber vermutlich ein getreues abbild der
allgemeinen entwicklung in der
europäischen union ist lokalisiert sich
wir haben mehr kräfte und die alten
großen zentren sind wir geschmolzen die
ergebnisse die wir bisher kennen sind
für die spd extrem enttäuschend also die
spd sichert zu retten das ist nur die
frage in welcher form also in der tat
ist sie ist natürlich jetzt engagiert
sie jetzt in der liga der der der
mittleren parteien die eigentlich nicht
mehr kanzler fähig sind das muss man so
sagen also wenn die spd jetzt eine
diskussion starten wird demnächst wer
kanzlerkandidat werden soll dann
entbehrt es nicht einer gewissen komik
weil weil dann müssen sich die grünen
vielmehr die frage stellen sollen nicht
wie er einen kanzlerkandidaten
aufstellen
es gibt so etwas wie eine grüne welle in
vielen ländern der europäischen union
das stimmt in frankreich sind die grünen
täten dritte kraft geworden
in vielen ländern scheinen die grünen in
das vakuum zu stoßen dass die
klassischen volksparteien hinterlassen
junge leute wählen die grünen in großer
zahl das sind stimmen für die demokratie
klimapolitisch spielt in deutschland
eine große rolle und das und das hat
alle ingredienzien eines einer einer
spannenden fragestellungen weil da geht
es von sozialer gerechtigkeit über
umweltschutz bis hin zu
wirtschaftspolitik also da hat man
sozusagen die ganze palette
es kann gut sein dass ich das ja
durchaus nahtlos wir neuwahlen haben in
einem bundestagswahlkampf entwickelt das
kann gut sagt die union hat einen klaren
führungsanspruch in deutschland wir sind
die europa partei deutschlands und das
hat auch dieser wahlsonntag deutlich
gemacht aufgaben sind sehr kompliziert
und sehr schwer sie erfordern gravierend
große kompromisse und ich bin nicht
sicher ob alle begriffen haben was die
stunde geschlagen hat auf der anderen
seite zeigt uns die große mobilisierung
zur wahl
dass die leute es verstanden haben
jedenfalls das was getan werden muss
dass sie sich engagieren wollen und dass
sie in der europäischen union ein wort
beträgt nun
es ist am ende